freundin kleines forward anstatt in
trance war es bei dieser folge sehr sehr
viel schief gegangen also meine tonspur
war total verrückt und irgendwie war
meine fans karason krohn das heißt ihr
habt gleich die ersten zwei minuten ist
gute qualität und danach es tonspur
asynchron und was weiß ich und die mein
ton ist gedämpft und da gedämpft oder
wie man das nennt so ein bisschen so
dumpf und die facetime ist ab der
zweiten liga nicht mehr aufgezeichnet
worden und was weiß ich alles was noch
passiert ich wollte mich nur kurz dafür
entschuldigen ich kann da nichts für ich
weiß nicht wer gerade umgezogen und habt
ihr vielleicht nicht alle einstellungen
perfekt vorgenommen tut mir leid ich
hoffe dass es bei der nächsten folge
also bei mir part 14 dann wieder okay
ist das wollte ich nur sagen und jetzt
trotzdem viel spaß falls sie denn jetzt
überhaupt noch
ja meine freunde willkommen zu einer
weiteren folge der nicht ab sondern
ketsch metro part 2 zusammen mit komma
de hallo wir haben uns gedacht wir waren
in der letzten folge bei com ist ein
bisschen am verzweifeln
wie läuft das alle die wappen mann da
vorne wie machen wir dies machen wir
denn die sprünge und alles mögliche und
ich gehe mal ganz kurz wirklich in den
harz machen
so soll zu machen lassen gar nix aber
leider cooper wie die aufgabe startete
der buletten sind ja auch auf gewisse
stand vorletzten folge letzte stein
verfolger wir standen dort wurde es ist
schon bald selbst erklärt wie steht ihr
ziel die jury sache etwas wie gedacht
hast du ja beginnt einfach mit geld dann
euro beruf ihr könnt ja das machen ich
weiß nicht was in dieser matt los ist
die sache deshalb wir haben da hinten
geschwindigkeit zu kommen laufen hier
vorne oben haben geschwindigkeit kommen
ich habe gedacht dass werden man bekommt
nämlich unten nur sieben sekunden dieses
dings nur sieben sekunden sprung
verstärkung da muss man hier hoch
springen und wir dachten dass das der
einzige sprung ist mannschaft muss aber
man muss auch diesen sprung schon die
haben wir alle der letzten folge gesehen
genau man kommt dann hier nicht
hochsprung verstärkungen aber es gibt
hier keine plattform falls wieder etwas
übersehen haben könnt ihr uns das geld
da gerne dann meckern aber wir sind
eigentlich noch mal auch am ende der
letzten folge im creative alles nochmal
abgeflogen
wir haben nichts verpasst haben keine
trendwende chance habt einfach nicht
denn ist ein bisschen traurig deswegen
habe man jetzt einfach hingesetzt und
herz der rest klappt also das wird auf
jeden fall nachher bei der bewertung der
app mit einfließen das relativ viel
nicht klappt dann da wird dann nicht so
toll da zittert mit euch hier auch schon
vor der tat nur bewährter bewertung
weise das ist doch hier du hast auch
gerade erst mal richtig einfallen lassen
damit den pokal
shampoos pro hinbekommen
grohl als schlagzeuger und bananen
banane
du brauchst erinnerungen du bist du
schon ich bin komplett ausgerüstet du
weißt dass ich mir am anfang komplett
auf legaler basis 30 millionen gebrachte
geld wieder im trainingslager man
freunde das ist auf die erste aufnahme
die gott nicht halt machen halte ich
wenn ich jetzt umgezogen wo lang links
oder nicht
jetzt muss ich mich erholen obwohl
wandel das schon vertreter sternen
banane internet läuft ich jedem ei kraft
läuft alles läuft und du hast ja immer
noch so ein leichtes hosen ganz wenig
ich habe meistens echo also ganz also im
vergleich zu früher früher war wirklich
alles perfekt ich war jetzt wenn man
ganz wenn man einmal das fine arts das
finance linke aber es ist so minimal
dass canepa macht nix also moment
erstmal checkpoint hier lag der total
dadurch erschwert eigentlich nein ich
bin wieder am netz
die darstellerin wo bist du ich habe es
geschafft anbrennen
ich habe ja noch trank der feier
résistance das verstehe ich auch nicht
ihr habt doch selber gesehen dass ich
auf den checkpoint drauf gedrückt habe
ok ich will mich im netz
guck mal ich drücke den checkpoint sogar
zweimal
und jetzt habe ich nicht meinen sprung
verstärkung
die müssen wir noch mal wohl jetzt mehr
gibt alles keinen sinn
obwohl er gut aber der im web aussteller
ist auch die trawler und ich das aber
ari trawler brauchen noch nicht eng wie
sinnvolle karten die brauchen nur ein
cooles texture pack gebrauch ein paar
coole ideen vollkommen überzeugt von
dieser karte aber mittlerweile dazu
ausreichen - was er gerade noch
vergessen
trawler brauchen an sich auch nur gebiet
wo sie sich den aufhalten können und
gegenseitig holen können darum geht es
ja meistens nur bei trawler kann worauf
ich bock hätte die komik http server
machen wenn wir nochmal zu spielen
nein wenn wir noch mal so eine karte
spiel rasch kommen will rap tracks
machen
das kommt ja auch noch andere hilfe
gleich aber ohne witz firma x motech
holt wechselt oder vierte bieten dann
seine karte spielt hat man ja atombomben
und so weiter und teilweise trawler
gerade spielt und das wäre verdammt
lustig oder
also ich würde es lustig finden wirklich
weg springt also das wäre doch ganz wc
wie meinte doch jetzt genau du meinst
jetzt dass man gegen eine mutter hat
noch zusätzlich
ich hab sie ahnt ja ich gespannt rang
thorsten teureres ertrank wieso hast du
den denn und ich nur von vorhin ich hab
das in seiner stadt pec in minecraft was
dann offene map angewendet wird geht
auch wenn wir würden wir keine ahnung
war wie rapidshare spielen wenn wir wenn
wir den anderen teil hiervon spielen
wenn wir sonst irgendeine karten spielen
sollten das wird dann einfach mal auf
dem server gleichzeitig noch mit pack
haben wo wir dann natürlich dadurch noch
newsroom und andere coole sachen wir uns
nicht direkt an die karte halten sondern
einfach mal keine ahnung so ein bisschen
freier orientieren und so ein bisschen
fun haben einfach weil wenn ich an
wechselt also denke da hat man solche
teile die konten meteorit mannschaft
nach art gibt es das beim pippis dingen
das notpaket und so und schlämmer vor
werden jetzt hier auf der karte noch
news
die wirklichen mega radius als schaden
was aber was bringt dir das beim jump
and run du möchtest mich nur um bringen
ja denn es geht ja ums thema liebe und
tod ist kein träumer
ich bin übrigens mal bei dieser tour
bereite im ice camps gerade ja und ich
packe sie aber nicht bin ich bin jetzt
unterwegs ich pack das jetzt glaube ich
aber du hattest rang der feier
resistenzen ja noch von vorhin den hatte
ich nämlich nicht das war ein bisschen
doof ich hoffe ich sollte auch nur ein
mitnehmen
jetzt muss aber das schafft er nicht ja
ich hasse abzulassen birne haste bananas
der krypta hast
ich frage mich mal in die luft als brief
an ihr immer wieder unterrichten
ja ich hätte aber wahrlich hälfte wollte
mich umbringen kommen schon für dich da
runter kommen runter hier alle die
werden dich gleich finden
kleider throl passte zum samt mail von
ihr
ich sehe keinen job sie kommen noch man
da oben ist noch viel mehr ob ich bin
nicht gestorben
jeder wusste anschließend noch viel mehr
aber nach oben
die kommende ich popkomm zu besen ja gut
wenn nicht heute scheiße tolle leute her
wird es länger den knopf gedrückt keine
ahnung was er bedeutet bei der ein herz
muss damit wohl endlich entschlossen ein
knopf gedrückt
der knappe sieg schießt mich jetzt auch
übrigens einfach nicht ab aber du musst
dich auch kollege carl bildt ist es ganz
gut ich mache mir meine eigenen dich
flugzeuge heute war ein richtig toller
tag wahrscheinlich einfach obwohl ich
der epische rosenke fall wahrscheinlich
dass mut gemacht
holzbalken
ich hab das doch gerade ich fasse es
nicht wir haben hier unter gewusst da
und jetzt wir wetten mein eigener körper
das bringt mich jetzt online wie werden
darunter dem springen noch weiter naja
aber jetzt bin ich ganz unten da wo du
auch eben fast und da kommst du raus am
ende so ein troll stimmt man kommt halt
wirklich ja ich war halt schon vorher
wird gott meine schuhe sind bald kaputt
sind jetzt müssen wir hier ein gelehrter
jetzt dax dax nicht und jetzt früher war
hier völlig gleich das bisschen trick
gewesen
am postschalter der manie meistens
kriege ich auch einfach nicht neu das
war an anderen anpacker bin hab ich kann
wieder auf den jackpot
wir haben ein warum springst du die
sprünge
eigentlich musste doch gar nicht extra
unter hier
ich mache etwa in die karten zu ende
kommt nicht so gesagt ja komm doch mal
in capital heft kann ich hab ein paar
gummibärchen auf wir schreiben so und er
einfach so gummibärchen machen komme
froh da war dass er gesagt
haribo macht kinder froh in den kommen
ebenso dann bin ich als erster hat du
hast gesagt in die ewigkeit
was ist dieser sprung ist der absolute
horror sprung geschafft paktiert
wünschen über den wolken
wer den wolken wir bleiben
ich hab schaden gekommen wieso denn
wieso der traktor zack zack ums
überleben sagt geschafft ich schaff das
jetzt übrigens freundin an alle die
jetzt hier denkt aber auch schon
bekommen
der schafft ja nie diese germans
denk wirtschaft geschafft 00 uhr von
julia schau mich an major wo wir mal
ganz kurz in diesem spreche dabei mir
auch sonova muss sich beeilen
ich hab was deswegen bin ich von runter
gefallen
so gesehen
ich hab ihn nur runter gefallen war ich
fix schaden bekommen habe weil ich
falsch haben bisschen bekommen habe man
aber jetzt halte ich mich daran bekomme
ich keinen fall schauen jetzt gehe ich
richtig gas
okay nicht was mein letzter traum wenn
ich selbst nicht packe dann natürlich
nicht ganz unauffällig kriegt keiner mit
jetzt gibt mir die zeit die ich schaffe
weil ich eben speedrun
truhe hallo truhen wo seid ihr tastatur
arbeitsprogramm weg ist der sportback
oder stirn ring sehr gering
und jetzt habe ich abgewartet und jetzt
läuft nämlich auch kosten leider sterben
dort konnten die jungs immer neue
insgesamt schon viel stück und detroit
mit 14 ja mal euren blog noch nichts
ich habe aber auch nur netter sterne
gefunden du bist du greifst gedreht
einmal und während ich mich im kreis
gedreht habe ich geschossen
wahrscheinlich hat er sich im kreis
getrennt
jedoch habe ich unter bist du da rein
gelaufen gut ich habe mich langsam im
kreis gedreht aber ich habe zwei minuten
im kreis wo bist du denn jetzt ja wieder
macht das jetzt noch mal schnell weil du
mich ja abgeschlossen hast wilhelma wer
schießt denn hier
ich schieße nicht bei mir eine aufnahme
nehmen beide weiblichste und sleep in
der bettenzahl please don't sleep inn
betz inside könig schlafmohn sommer
gemeinsam jetzt letzte mich da bitte mal
vernünftig ich hätte eine
schwangerschaft man es tut mir leid das
ganze immer noch ein bisschen länger
laut nenne ich dachte dass das verstehe
ich
ich mach das nenne ich habe die letzten
jahr noch nicht geschafft ich habe
gesagt ich brauche mich nur weil etwas
nicht geht wenn ich keine lust habt wenn
ich es nicht schaffe
wenn ich
oh ich hab hier in das iglu und sein
librettist es mal ganz groß ob der
jackpot punkt okay ist es normal sei
wahrscheinlich
welcome to play offs tg steve system
eintragen
ich habe mich aus versehen in die wetten
reingelegt heißt das dass jetzt da man
checkt man ist das solltest du nicht tun
habe ich aber gut und ich will damit
sagen dass wir damit die folge beenden
weil das so eine grandios dumme aktion
wieder von mir war aber nie die folge
see vorbei diese stehen den kopf dass er
komisch aber wir sehen die nächste folge
auch gomez kanal die pause kommt nämlich
morgen und dann sehen wir uns dort